when you flip on a tv or stream a game
online to see women competing in sports
across the u.s
understand that's in part the legacy of
title ix
this month marks the 50th anniversary of
the barrier-breaking federal law that
changed the game for gender equity in
education and athletics
first off you may be wondering what
exactly title ix is
this federal civil rights law was
authored chiefly by representative patsy
mink the first woman of color elected to
the u.s congress with support from
representative edith greene and senator
birch bai
the 1972 civil rights legislation states
in part
no person in the united states shall on
the basis of sex be excluded from
participation in be denied benefits of
or be subjected to discrimination under
any education program or activity
receiving federal financial assistance
this law initially focused on ensuring
that women would have equitable
opportunities to receive educations and
earn degrees and it prohibited
discrimination on the basis of gender
identity and sexual orientation as well
as pregnancy parenting and abortion
status the legislation also prohibited
discrimination on the basis of blindness
and visual impairment and provided
protections against sexual harassment
and violence now without the word
activity as a part of the law the impact
of title ix may never have been felt in
sports but the legislation ultimately
pertains to equity in everything from
admissions financial aid and
scholarships to schools having to
provide equally for men's and women's
athletics at the time few women were
admitted into universities and receiving
an athletic scholarship felt like a pipe
dream
to those who did want to compete they
usually had to join intramural club
teams along with shouldering the
financial burden themselves in fact in
1975 mink had to fight to keep athletics
regulations included in title ix with
congress ultimately preserving the
sports component of the legislation
before its passage one in 27 girls
played sports in the united states by
2016 according to the women's sports
foundation
one in every five girls in this country
were participating before title ix
around 32 000 college women participated
in sports as of the 2019-2020 academic
year
over 224 000 women played college sports
per usa today but gender equity still
has a long way to go the existence of
title ix wasn't a magic wand it served
as a new standard violations of which
there would now be greater pressure to
address just last year seven women
including three former athletes brought
a lawsuit against louisiana state
university saying the school mishandled
and in some cases even discouraged title
ix complaints from these women alleging
sex-based discrimination
including rape sexual assault sexual
harassment and or stalking perpetrated
by male lsu students
in early 2022 five female coaches
reached a settlement with colby college
after filing a discrimination complaint
alleging the school provided more
resources to the men's teams and paid
its men's and women's coaches unequally
in 2021 clemson university athletes won
a title ix settlement after both male
and female athletes issued claims that
their title ix protections were being
violated with the men's varsity track
and field and cross-country teams cut
and the women's rowing cross country and
track and field teams reporting that
they weren't receiving equal athletic
financial aid treatments or benefits
the men's and women's teams mobilized
stood together and made a significant
leap toward equality for all
title ix disrupted a system upholding
sexism and transformed girls and women's
athletics forever but we still need to
use the groundbreaking legislation of 50
years ago as inspiration to further
strengthen protections for trans
athletes and sexual assault survivors to
prevent discrimination and hold
institutions accountable because we are
all created equally the law
and the gain
should reflect that